No what am i doing between I know  keeping this PG way what am i doing is  that PG bungee  pretty much bone related  we like combination so  it's so true she's on her own planets  okay the electric slide doesn't count in  the dance move it's not that that's not  dancing  highlight areas sir because we all laugh  a lot  if you have Marion see the oldest wives  so I got an advice from you okay thanks  well you can teach you a pretty great  Bob  Jodie's and Simone's is gonna bag yeah  good night ladies one-year-old  choreographers teaching us the moves to  the right stuff and we're like um that's  not how it's done let us tell you how to  do the new kids on the block  choreography so we know none of us sees  our uncle and then of us [ __ ] Maggie  above you yeah well the only three women  on the planet that don't tell him  anything for him